but if we miscalculate by even one meter
these
are engineering problems my friends
and we are engineers
shall we begin
hey guys pete here it's time to talk
about the eighth episode of for all
mankind's third season no big surprise
that there's a crisis on mars but this
episode seemed more concerned with
adding layers to the characters they've
worked pretty hard to make unlikable and
continue to add layers to the ones we
like while putting them in difficult
situations on the brighter side nick is
reunited with pj alexey survives the
landslide and ed and danny finally have
that heart to heart we are getting into
the final stretch and i'll be breaking
the whole thing down and that will of
course contain spoilers with that out of
the way let's get into it at happy
valley base they experience the effects
of the landslide they figure out pretty
quickly that it's not a mars quake and
when they can't make contact with helios
base danielle tells will and roland that
they're going to have to go out in the
rover to investigate she tells them that
whatever personal issues they have going
on they need to squash them and nothing
like a crisis to bring people back
together it looks like that's mostly
been smoothed over we watch as alexei
emerges from the dust it turns out that
the landslide buried him but he survived
he's not able to reach anyone on the
radio and he looks like he may have
sustained some injury as we watch him
vomit inside his suit nearby he
discovers nick's body his space shield
was shattered so he didn't last long and
the first thing i thought about here was
danny's culpability for what happened in
the accident nick was the only one that
was there and knew that danny decided
not to act to vent the pressure back on
earth we get a scene with ellen and pam
having their talk she shows her the
letter and they talk about how things
ended pam admits that she lied and gave
her up because she thought that one day
she could make a real difference for
people like them and she's been
disappointed since she's been sworn in
all she's seen her do is make compromise
after compromise ellen delivers a
reasonable response saying sometimes you
have to settle for what's possible and
they do both make their points before
they get interrupted because ellen has
to leave because of the situation on
mars there's a lot of history and you
can feel the emotion between these two
who are in an almost absurd situation
given the fact that ellen is the
president of the united states the big
takeaway though is that it feels like
there's seeds planted here for ellen to
do something with her power that might
redeem her in the love of her life's
eyes or maybe not she could decide to
hold on to that power and this would
make that feel all the more tragic at
helios they decide to send all the
engineers over to nasa to coordinate a
rescue attempt karen stays behind
because she says someone needs to visit
the families this feels like a call back
to her role in season one all those nasa
wives getting together and it's in
contrast for the person that karen has
become but her ex-husband and her
daughter are in the middle of this
crisis and if anybody understands what
those families are going through it's
her deb looks shook and he vows to do
everything in his power to rescue ed and
he says it in the way that seems sincere
alexei finds louisa and she explains
that isabelle didn't make it danny talks
to phoenix in orbit and finds out that
they make contact with hab2 which has a
busted antenna that's making
communications difficult and they can't
raise ed and danny who are trapped in
have one there we find dany patching up
ed's injury they're in the airlock of
hab one and they're buried there's an
emergency beacon transmitting and if
they're not too deep then there is a
chance they could be dug out at nasa
they assess the variety of problems
they're facing the msam is inoperable so
everyone on the surface is stuck there
and they know there wouldn't be much air
or much time for the people trapped in
have one
we see dany start to lose hope as they
realize they have maybe six hours of
breathable air danielle and her team
arrive at hab 2 and eventually alexei
and louisa make it back they're able to
work out where they were and alexei and
kelly go out with ground penetrating
radar to search for hab one they have a
talk while they search where she brings
up her fears about losing her father he
tries to make her feel better by telling
her about his father and you can see
that this has turned into a real
relationship we also learned that he has
a bad headache that he can't shake after
the landslide and they do eventually
pick up the beacon signal jimmy and
amber stevens are watching the news
coverage on tv jimmy has a moment where
he's really disturbed by the fact that
they are advertising erectile
dysfunction pills in the commercial
break and then karen arrives to sit with
them and help her keep busy by cooking
dinner as they're eating she breaks down
crying and this does a lot to establish
the character some because we haven't
really got to know her yet eventually
they will get a call telling them that
they located the hab and that brings
some temporary relief although jimmy is
still acting weird because he thinks
this is all some kind of cover-up for
something more nefarious at nasa they
realize hab1 is buried 20 meters deep
they know that they don't have that long
to dig though because they're gonna run
out of air and it's kind of funny when
you think about it that they had all of
these different sides spread out all
competing for everything and they still
found a way to bring it back to nasa
mission command which gives it that same
feeling that we've had over the last
couple of seasons margot notices deb
isn't in the conference room and decides
to go look for him and elena asks bill
if the soviets ever say anything about
margot he doesn't really know why she's
asking but it's just to remind us of
that storyline that they didn't really
touch on in this episode when she finds
deb they have a conversation telling the
same story he told karen back in episode
two she brings up her relationship with
her dad which we remember learning about
in season one and then things turn a
little bit when he tells her that his
father worked at kirkland and lost his
job after apollo 23 exploded on the pad
he spent the rest of his life looking
for work but never found anything
meaningful and he never really recovered
he passed away before deb graduated
college and this is the part of the
story he usually leaves out because he
says people like to hear about success
in america they don't like to hear about
failure they share a moment where
there's mutual respect she tells him
that she thinks that his father would be
proud of him just as her estranged
father was for her in his own way she
goes back in and asked if he'll join
them and he says in a minute and stays
there to think when he returns he brings
up a dangerous plan that could work and
you see everyone sort of discredit it
first and then realize they don't really
have many other options they'll have to
enter a lava tube and blow a hole below
the hab so the debris can flow down like
grain from a hopper after it drains
they'll be able to access it from above
and it's a pretty good solution as long
as they don't blow up the hab in the
process everyone has concerns and dev
brings up the perfect line probably one
of the best lines in the episode to calm
them down
saying these are engineering problems my
friends and we are engineers
and this is a turn for the character at
least the way we look at him and it kind
of emphasizes what this story is all
about humanity has its problems
individuals have their problems but in
moments of crisis they can put that
stuff aside and they can work together
and they can do amazing things
ellen returns to the white house larry
kind of gets upset that she didn't tell
him where she was going and he freaks
out some whenever she says she went to
see pam it's pretty easy for her to turn
that around because
well all the stuff he's been doing they
argue and when the vice president shows
up she asks him to give them the room so
she's kind of shutting him out here
danny and ed have no idea that the
rescue's underway and they're arguing as
well and this time he brings up shane
with a pretty surgical you're not
teaching me to ride a bike of course i
don't think he knows how much this will
get to ed but it turns out to be the
right thing to really get him worked up
he provokes him to the point of hitting
him and he opens his wound and they're
able to use a anti-clotting agent to
stop the bleeding it all looks pretty
painful and i think you can see danny
showing some remorse as he's stopping
the bleeding what's interesting about
this time with ed and danny is that
initially danny's the one that gives up
he can't see a reason to go on and later
they're gonna flip this upside down and
they're both being affected by the
weight of the situation there's a really
good chance they're gonna die and they
think that they're at the end of their
lives ed has his regrets danny's been
living with his shame so i really
appreciated how they sort of played
these two characters off each other and
it kind of fits with this overall idea
of making these characters a little more
human and where that really pays off is
when karen tries to talk to jimmy and he
brings up that he knows about the affair
between her and danny she's taken off
guard but then she eventually comes
clean and even listens when he tells her
that she used him i suppose this is part
of what's been missing from this story
the complicated reasons for how it
affected him jimmy says danny always
tried to please everyone and we see this
from the other side when he's talking to
ed and they think they're about to die i
don't know if it's enough to bring us
around on danny especially after what he
did in the last episode and we're still
in the aftermath of that people are
dying but seeing what he's done through
jimmy's perspective who went a
completely different way in his trauma
adds another dimension alexei collapses
and vomits when they get back to the hab
the doctor suspects that he's suffering
from a subdural hematoma they'll have to
drill a hole in his skull to relieve the
pressure and they're going to need a
blood transfusion and it turns out that
kelly is a match and that'll be
important later because they're going to
be looking at her blood will and roland
work together they get their job done
they place the explosives we see them
triple check everything and then get
ready to run before they detonate the
charge back in hab one the oxygen levels
are low danny says he'll help ed to get
into the suits and this time ed's the
one that says it doesn't matter he's the
one who's giving up he expresses regret
for fighting with kelly the last time
they talked she was angry and we saw
that he dismissed her and this reminds
him of the last time he talked to shane
when he yelled at him and told him to be
a man this is something we wanted to see
ed get to i think because he's been
doing the same thing with danny and it's
been causing problems and danny
apologizes for what he said taking
responsibility for all the trouble he
got into with shane i don't think that
that was ever clear before and he was
happy to let everyone think that it was
shane he says that he dragged him into
all of it and let him take the heat what
kills him is that he forgave him every
time part of that was that he was afraid
of ed he was unhappy at home so he
really cared about this friendship and
now he feels responsible for what
happened basically if shane had never
met him then he wouldn't have died and
the really sad part is from that moment
back when they were 12 or how old they
were back when we saw him over at the
house and that moment he had with karen
he thought that if he lived the life
shane could have had maybe it would make
up for it and now he feels like he
failed that he's ruined his life he's
gonna leave his daughter behind just
like his mom and dad left him and his
brother and we see that ed is overcome
with emotion and just tries to comfort
him saying it's okay it's okay he's
about to confess that he's the one who
slept with karen as they are about to
pass out and eventually die when we hear
the explosion and then they're saved
amber and karen get the call that they
made it jimmy finds out this is a really
great scene this show is so good at
putting together those emotional moments
everyone working together everyone
solving the problem somebody celebrating
that and you're right there with them
and they hit it again one more time a
little while later ed wakes up
apparently he'll be okay alexi did not
make it though ed learns about the
others kelly is shattered over losing
alexei and he comforts her and they made
it through this crisis but there are
still a lot of problems primarily how do
they get back to phoenix and then how do
they get back to earth and we're gonna
have to wait to the next episode to find
out everyone from helios and ross cosmos
leaves nasa devin margot share a look
and there's a shot of her looking at the
empty room and smiling this is that shot
that comes after the celebration just a
short look helps you remember all of the
triumphs they had why margot is such a
crucial character to everything that
happened at nasa and considering her
situation the fact that she's
compromised this felt like a bad omen to
me sort of that one last shot they show
the character before they kill him off i
mean i don't think they're gonna kill
margot off here i think she's going to
end up in prison or something along
those lines but especially the second
time i watched this it felt like it was
setting something up back on mars the
two remaining soviets talk the commander
asked what do we do about the baldwin
girl because they figured out that she's
pregnant this probably happened during
the blood transfusion and they don't
think that she knows yet and they don't
say a lot here but it does feel like
it's supposed to be ominous they say
they have to tell moscow first and say
that she could be a threat to the entire
crew i'm not sure i understand why they
think that but it gives us something to
think about in between episodes because
this one ends right there
some great character development in this
episode and we also lost quite a few of
them nick and isabelle may have been
minor but it's still sad to see them go
think about what that experience must be
like so far away from home i think the
population of mars was 13. so three
deaths means they shed 20 percent of
that in a 24-hour period not to mention
losing the hab and the supplies and the
m sam danny is 100 responsible for this
and while they did a good job of
injecting some humanity under the
surface of his character's situation i'm
not sure how his commander or any of the
other astronauts would be able to
overlook that kelly lost the father of
her future child and everyone's survival
is on the line because he was wasted at
the console it'll be interesting to see
if he's able to fly under the radar
because of nick's death there's a lot up
in the air which is a nice way to set up
a fantastic ending i thought it was
absolutely promising to see them go back
and reconnect to so many things that
happened to these characters over the
past decades i can't wait to see where
things go from here and i think that's a
good place to leave things let me know
in the comments what you think about
this episode and where we'll go next
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon